It starts from the beginning.
Nobody told me to win
Wimbledon at 17.
I just did it.
[announcer]
Wimbledon champion, Boris Becker.
My game was power.
Mental strength.
That's how I would describe Boris.
He was like
Michael Jordan in Germany.
Expectations in the tennis world.
Becoming a superstar in sports.
You're now a wanted man.
To pick a black woman
as his wife was a big deal.
In the German press it
was a black and white thing.
When you step away
from the game you come into
a completely different life.
It's sort of walking into a dark room.
She came in, she had a big coat on
and she took the coat off
and she was heavily pregnant.
You just can't believe it.
The wake-up call came very late.
[announcer]
Boris Becker is facing two and a half
years in jail for hiding assets
[announcer]
during bankruptcy.
I've hit my, my bottom.
That's not the end yet.
There's going to be another chapter.